こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
俺
今年の夏のやりたいこと
できましたはじめ社長の3億円のお家の
とある場所に
隠シェルターを置いたんですよちょっと前
に購入した動画も出したんですけども
オレンジにね
隠してるがありましてやばい時の避難用に
これ買ったんですけれども
置いておくだけで普段全く使ってないん
ですよ今
非常食とか避難用のグッズだけ中に入れて
全然使い道がなくて
俺思ったんですよ何かに使えないかなと
私は社長
[音楽]
ヘラクレスオオカブト
育てます
男の夢あのはじめしゃちょー小さい頃から
虫がとっても好きでちょっと感謝で電話し
て聞いてみるか自分で口で言っても信用
ならないでしょおかんに電話しよう一番
ちっちゃい頃の俺のそばで見ていたのは俺
のお母様です出るかな
もしもし動画撮ってるけどいいですか
お願いします
ちっちゃい頃の話なんですけどこれ
めっちゃ虫好きじゃなかったですか
はいちょっとヘラクレスオオカブト育て
ますわ
この人
反対されましたが僕はもう大人なので自分
の責任で育てますというわけでカブトムシ
とかクワガタとかちっちゃい頃たくさん虫
も育ててたし好きなんですよ
虫育てるの普通のカブトムシって日本の虫
だからこう日本の気候に合わせて育て
られるんですけどもヘラクレスオオカブ
トって日本の虫じゃないのよ絶対地域かな
日本とは全然季節とか気候とかが違う場所
の生き物を日本で育てるのってちょっと
大変でしてそれを可能にできるの
ここしかないかなと思いまして
ここで育てますというわけで中を見る前に
あのもうね買ってきたんですよ
ヘラクレスオオカブトオスとメス見せ
ちゃいますね
ただね買うにあたってねやっぱちゃんと
責任を持って育てたいから結構色々ね下
準備と勉強とかペットショップのその
虫専門の人に話を聞いたりして知識は
かなり詰めましたでも結局生き物だからね
何が正しいとかってなかなかないんです
けど
俺好きなのよ
昆虫とかカブトムシとかクワガタとかそれ
は話そう痛い痛い痛い痛いダメでしょ
暴力は行って紹介させてくださいこちらが
はじめしゃちょーのヘラクレスオオカブト
のオスです
かっこよすぎだろうヘラクレスって
いろんな種類があるんですけど俺この背中
が黄色のやつが好きなんですよこの光沢ね
見てこのかっこよさヘラクレス何がかっこ
いいかといってやっぱ角ですよねこの
ハサミギロチンいやもうイケメンすぎだろ
なんでそんなかっこいい生まれ方したんだ
皆さんこれがヘラクレスオオカブトですよ
かっこいいねそしてこっちが
ヘラクレスオオカブトのメスですねメス俺
お店でずっと店たくさん見てたんですけど
も男を飼いならすタイプのメスですねこれ
はきっといい奥さんになってくれるかなと
思いますはいこういう感じで押すとメスを
買いましたマジで
仲良くしてほしいなんか本当に性格次第な
んですってワンチャンねストレスとかで
どっちかが死んじゃったりすることもある
しもうそれはねこの子達の愛称次第なので
ちょっと一概には言えないんですけど結構
広めのは買ったんですけどもちょっと
仲良く
暮らしてほしいですはいというわけで本題
に移りましょうシェルターの中ちょっと見
ていきたいと思いますはいでは中入って
いきます
[音楽]
失礼します
物はまだ全然少ないんですけど色々と準備
はしておりますはいえっとね
核シェルターでヘラクレスオオカブトを
育てる利点たくさんありましてまず
温度調整がめっちゃ楽なんです音ゲー
ちゃんと持ってるんですけども
ヘラクレスオオカブトが一番過ごしやすい
温度が22°cから25度で今24°cな
ので
ちょうどいいぐらいなんですよ部屋が
小さいので
温度調整がめちゃくちゃ
楽ですで直射日光もカブトムシ絶対NGな
ので太陽も絶対ここには入ってきません
もう完璧なのよその時点で湿度も心配なん
ですけども加湿器しっかり炊いてますもう
万全な状態で育てられるんじゃないかと私
は思ったわけですよ他にもね色々買ってき
ました
温度計質時計はもちろん
霧吹き水取っても大事なので結構常に
湿らせておきます高タンパク質の昆虫
ゼリー高タンパク質なのが大事ですね
コバエは絶対沸くので倍ホイホイとか
カブトムシ倒れるとケースの中だと
起き上がりにくいので木とか買ったりあと
ヘラクレス専用のもう土とかも買わせて
もらいました
ずーっとご飯食べてるんですねもう
もぐもぐしてますね
ずっと食べてますね
さっき買ってきたばかりで全然まだ木くず
みたいなところにいるのでしっかり
ヘラクレスたちのちょっとこのお部屋
きれいにしてあげたいと思いますお引越し
の時間ですなんか本当はねもうちょっと
大きい容器を買ってあげたかったんです
けど大きいのがなくて後々ですねそれはお
引越ししますよ
皆さんお引越ししまーす
ご飯中ごめんよごめんよご飯中に失礼し
ます
入れます
[音楽]
よしよしこんなもんかな全然全部じゃない
んですけどこれ下の3/5ぐらいだとして
硬く押し込みますこれなんでこんなこと
するかというと
卵を産む時に3/5が硬くないとダメなん
だって結構ねバチバチに硬くしちゃって
大丈夫ですOKかなり硬くなったかな
のにまた入れ直しますいやなんかね無駄に
知識だけつけてるんだけどなんか調べれば
調べるほどみんなね言ってること結構違う
のよ正直何が正しくて何が間違ってるのか
よくわかんないからなんとなく自分の中で
正しいそうだなって思ったのをちょっと
信じてやってってますまあ生き物なん
でしょうね正解ないからね
[音楽]
OK自宅場所
暴れてる
[音楽]
どうしたやっぱちょっと狭いのかな
角がさ長すぎて当たっちゃうのよね
ちょっともうちょっと広いの準備して
あげるから待っててくれよあとゼリーは
多めがいいんですって
常に切らさず置いておくといいって書いて
ありました
是非ですどうでしょう
[音楽]
食べた食べたよしよしちゃんとパクパク
食べてますよかったよかった1本メスは
もうねずーっと食べてるのよね
食いしん坊ですねはいこんな感じです
ちょっと狭いな本当に大きくしてあげる
いつか使えずにちょっと大きくして
あげようちょっと狭そうだったので一生
ケースに移し替えました結構広いですよ
結局大きめの方がいいって話を聞いたので
衣装ケースくらいがめちゃくちゃいいって
聞いたので
オスメスに仲良くするんだったらこれ
ぐらいのサイズがいいんじゃないかって
ことでこのサイズにさせてもらいました
だいぶでかいぞずっと食べてるな
[音楽]
食べてるなまあいいだろう仲良く過ごして
くれればそれでいいよはいというわけで
ヘラクレスオオカブトをオスメス買いまし
たなんかねちょっと
ヘラクレスオオカブトって難しい
イメージあるんですけども
温度調節さえしっかりしてればそんなに
難しくないで有名です本当に22度から
25°c今が24°c完璧だね
適正の温度22°cから25°cをキープ
して
乾燥しすぎないように水作りをたまに
吹きかけてあとはどうしてもコバエが出て
きちゃうのでコバエホイホイとかコバエが
来ないネットとかいろんな対策があるので
コバエを対策するいろいろ気にしなきゃ
いけないことあるんですけどもざっくり
このレベルらしいです本当に
意外と簡単なんだってなんかまだほんと
色々あるんですよなんかメスだけ
ゼリーを十字カットして2つに入れて
あげるとか色々気にしなければいけない
こともあったり普通に育てるかこの2匹を
交尾させて繁殖させるとかとかなんか目的
に応じて全然育て方も変わってくると思う
んですけれどもまあ僕は寿命いっぱい来て
くれればいいかなとでも子供もできたら
ちょっと嬉しいなぐらいの感じでしたいと
思いますはいもちろん責任をしっかり持っ
て育てたいと思います
忙しい時とか東京に行く時とか絶対あると
思うのでそういう時のために弟が俺の家に
住んでいたり大地君だったり周りの人とか
みんなでちゃんと責任を持ってお世話して
いこうと思いますがもうね生き物である
以上どうしても
病気になっちゃったり死んじゃったりする
ことはあると思うのでその時は仕方ないん
ですけどたくさん愛情を振りまいて育てて
いきたいと思いますあとね普通に好きなの
よかっこよすぎでしょだってなんかね
いろいろあるのよねあのオスオスで買うと
喧嘩してストレスで死ぬのがメスメスで
育てると喧嘩して死ぬとかなんか同性が
なんか良くないという説もあるし逆にオス
とメスメスで買うとかおすすめしめすで
買うとなんか色んな作戦があるんですけど
どうしようかな
恋愛リアリティ賞行く
[音楽]
[拍手]
寂しそうだったらちょっと多すぎ1匹メス
1匹増やしちゃってもいいとも思います
けどじゃあ皆さんマジで安心してください
あのーヘラクレス愛マジですごいんで
責任もって育てたいと思いますで
ヘラクレスの寿命なんですけども
成虫になってから6ヶ月から12ヶ月半年
から1年1年以上生きることもあるみたい
です女の子が今年の1月に羽化して男の子
が今年の3月に羽化しました
女の子もうすぐ半年ってことになると最速
でメスは
7月とかにはもう寿命が尽きる可能性もあ
るって事ですね
夏前やんけ3月1月2ヶ月たか歳の差
カップルやなお前年上のお姉様大事にする
んだぞ少なくともペットショップのなんか
ちっちゃいこういう中でいるよりかは
幸せな生活がさせてあげれたらいいなと
思っておりますちょっとあの今年の夏虫と
いうかちょっと昆虫ブームが自分の中で来
てるのでなんかまた動画にできたら動画に
したいと思いますじゃあな
[音楽]